all over the place on shows like talk
soup the showtime drama queer as folk
and the cerebral classic dude where's my
car
and you can see his van halen tribute
show at count vamped rock bar and grill
you can see him right now because he's
here on las vegas that's right that's
all you need yeah i mean don't don't
pass up on it immediately come down so
counts fam we're also doing stand up the
show is punch lines and back lines yeah
so uh uh chris kale from uh the five
finger death punch is going to try stand
up for the first time tonight wow along
with myself and and it's not your first
time no no i've been doing since i was
14. yeah so i've met you know i should
be good at it at this point at this
point yeah yeah
at some point yeah i mean you know some
people will blame the audience after
you've been on the road long enough
you're just basically a massage
therapist you can't go like i can't do
anything you're too tense you know you
just got to get at it and nerd halen
started how you know i i do the ultimate
jam night at the whiskey which in la
which is on the sunset strip and it's
amazing and every week they throw
different songs at you and we're mixing
with like big hair metal bands and
artists we all just kind of mix and do a
song without rehearsing it and our
guitar player caleb who nails eddie van
halen on the uh sound alike meter and it
came up to me and he was like i'm gonna
try to do i don't know this thing i'm
trying to it's i need to sing and it's a
cha it's called nerd hail and i was like
i'm in
i mean immediately
but you're a legit musician too yeah
yeah i know i'm an amazing singer and a
killer guitar player that's that's true
nobody nobody cares about that when
you're on lab rats on disney you know
what i mean as a matter of fact they're
like can you keep that part down
but um but yeah i mean in my i grew up
my dad's a bluegrass musician in our
family you grow up learning to play you
must honor the instruments by playing
them well or don't pick them up yeah and
uh i was you know i'm i started out as a
rough singer
now we're doing uh hagar notes in these
shows we do turn into nerd hagar a
couple of times during the show so if
you're a van halen fan it's the entire
spectrum sometimes you don't get that
sometimes you know when you go see a
tribute band it's only one era right
right you know we we try to honor all of
them talk about spectrum your career has
you've done everything you mentioned
stand up yeah of course music and you've
done a lot of acting not to mention the
hosting on talk soup but uh all sorts of
movies you've been in dude where's my
car spider-man 2 you had a scene that
people remember in an elevator right yep
all improv i mean they needed improv
yeah they needed a genius and i was
luckily i was available for a weekend um
ask sam raimi he directed it he knows
he'll tell you but um
you know i started out in chicago doing
stand-up and acting and it's it's not a
a magic town like la or even new york is
nobody really taps you on the shoulder
and gets like yeah i got moxie kids you
gotta be in pictures nobody even thinks
that in chicago it's just a ladder you
just start where you are and get better
and eventually people will honor you
with better work so i was like that's
something i wrapped my head around
started doing stand up started my first
band in high school and and got uh you
know my first acting gigs when i was
living there but you peaked at age 11
when you became a dungeon master i read
about this today my library at the at
the public library in p in frankfurt
kentucky the capitol for the who's at
home
and uh yeah i was i i basically that's
what happens when you're 11 years old
and you're smarter than the 20s 20 year
olds around you and that's why they made
me leave the state you know because you
went there yeah yeah i read far too much
that goes over really well in kentucky
yeah i mean it's like the old kentucky
joke about i had a friend who was
arrested for smuggling books into
kentucky but nobody but he got on on a
technicality because nobody could prove
they were books that's that was my life
that was when i was 14 i was like i
gotta go
so yeah the long hair i haven't seen
before but you say this is like you've
been wearing long hair on and off for my
life i've had long hair except when i
work on you know like shows when we say
yeah like where's folk and other stuff
like that but this is just how i choose
to be and i started growing this at the
beginning of the current unpleasantness
you know right right at lockdown i was
like and you moved to las vegas yeah
yeah well my girlfriend and i have a
place here and we just hunkered down
because that's what we had to do you had
to make that decision so as a family we
decided one city however long this lasts
let's do it and luckily familiarity did
not breed contempt we still love each
other and that's i in in my town in l.a
what i mean that's that's heavy little
well we're glad you're here too and tell
tell us again where we can see tonight
it counts vamped uh punch lines and back
lines it's stand up and then nerd halen
will perform we're also going to be at
the m in january but and we're at the
monsters of rock crews uh land show the
uh monsters on the mountain in august as
well so hal sparks it is great to have
antibiotics you've got short hair good
both ways a genius on top of it all to
only to